arrêtons est en train d'apparaître ce
lien pour bastia merci mathieu avec les
britanniques
et l'appareil que le duc de kent à
fatiguer
[Musique]
bavardages avec son arrière petit fils
louis
émerveillement devant les avions de la
royal air force qui survole londres
point d'orgue quand les 70 ans du jubilé
de platine s'inscrivent dans le ciel
boris johnson et ciani maccione le
premier ministre
l'adhésion
est souvent le cas
extrêmement et
d'angleterre elizabeth ii elle aime les
plaisirs de la vie on va découvrir de
petites images assez insolite regarder
la reine qui boit de la bière
normalement photographie jamais la reine
en train de boire ni manger environ 20%
de notre territoire est sous le contrôle
des occupants près de 125 mille
kilomètres carrés c'est beaucoup plus
que le territoire de tous les pays du
benelux ces débordements devant le stade
de france samedi soir
65% des français les trouve honteux
selon ce sondage csa pour ses news des
pillages et des violences qui inquiète
60% d'entre eux près de 12 millions
d'ukrainiens sont devenus des déplacés
internes plus de 5 millions pour la
plupart des femmes et des enfants sont
partis à l'étranger à l'extrême droite
demandent à peu près tous les trois mois
la démission du ministre de l'intérieur
quel qu'il soit quels que soient les
gouvernements
donc ça en tout cas il ya une forme de
cohérence et de continuité est la part
de l'extrême droite sur le sujet à la
fois de la part la sénatrice êtes
vous-même de qu'évoquer avec beaucoup d'
insulte la seine saint denis et qui
depuis plusieurs heures voire plusieurs
jours évoque une essentialisation la
délinquance en évoquant des nationalités
en mettant en pâture un certain nombre
de liens très nauséabond qui font
malheureusement l'écho d'une campagne
présidentielle que pourtant les
extrémistes ont perdu je la trouve
percement x extrêmement déplacé c'est
quoi ce qu'ils aient à sa règle par des
bandes qui sont venus pour détrousser
pour agresser des supporters pourquoi
ils ont tant de mal quand vous dites ça
vous avez alors ce déni permanent de ce
ministre et ce gars ne m'en lasse pas
nouveau du mensonge mais surtout de
mépris parce que à partir de jeudi ça
j'avais des propos nauséabonds dont
barrage havrais bien qui les qualifie et
surtout j'étais évidemment une facho le
président nous a parlé sont et il va
parler et for education aujourd'hui
pourquoi il parle pas sécurité le chef
de l'état est aujourd'hui à marseille
aux côtés du nouveau ministre de
l'éducation pap ndiaye pour faire la
promotion de l'école du futur je suis
pas là
augmenter la qualité va continuer de se
faire en fonction justement des rapports
qui seront rendues et de ce qui sera
établie par toutes les parties prenantes
qui ont eu à connaître de ce qui s'est
passé et pendant ce temps là le
président de la république la première
ministre ils n'ont pas présenté leur
programme et donc je pense que faute
d'avoir présenté leur programme et
cherchent à nourrir des polémiques
pathétique pitoyable lui qui s'occupe
même de beaucoup de choses et bien
souvent de tous c'est bizarre que le
tuner pas son avis parce que je vais
vous dire une chose il a adressé un
message au patron
je vais vous dire une chose
vous allez vous entendre avec moi
pour une raison simple
vous n'aurez pas le choix l'acteur
johnny depp est sorti grand gagnant de
son procès l'opposant à son ex épouse
amber heard niveau de la cabine de vivre
dans le pas de calais regarder un pan de
la falaise s'est écroulée tôt ce matin
dans sa chute il a entraîné le blockhaus
de la pointe de la rochette le jury a
décidé que l'actrice a diffamé son ex
époux en se décrivant comme victimes de
violences conjugales elle devra verser
15 millions de dommages et intérêts à
johnny depp l'acteur lui devrait verser
2 millions à son ex épouse